playing piano I'm also the director of
the group and I'm the one who compiles
the scores which is to select which
music out of this library we use once
the movie gets started i'm actually not
doing a lot while they're playing I'm
the accompanist I'm filling in the
backgrounds but not really playing much
in the foreground occasionally if we end
a piece soon i improvise to fill the
spaces in the score so that there aren't
gaps of silence and I am Don creamerum
the trumpet player in Mont Alto been
with the group for I don't know eight or
nine years something like that and a lot
of the times the orchestration doesn't
have a ton of trumpet playing so I'm
playing a lot of clarinet cute clarinet
2 q's horn Q's bassoon q is kind of
whatever happens to be in my part and
I'm Brian Collins I play clarinet and
besides playing clarinet sometimes I
have to cover second trumpet cues or
second violin or viola so um you know I
get to play a variety of things a lot of
inner voices but occasionally I do get
to plays some of the leads in the pieces
I'm David short I'm the chalice with
Montalto as you can see um the the cello
parts in this music is is a little bit
different than what you'd find in a
classical symphony score a lot of the
times I'm playing every thing ah I play
the bass lines when necessary i switched
to second violin parts viola parts
second clarinet parts horn parts bassoon
parts really whatever's needed to kind
of fill out what's already going on
because Rodney over there can play most
of the bass lines on his on the piano
I'm Britt Swenson I'm the violinist in
on alto and I love playing with this
group I feel like it's such a chamber
music experience a lot of times I play
the flute cues because Rodney has scored
it from a much bigger score down to our
group of five and beautiful lyrical
music I sometimes play the sad melodies
and sometimes you know whatever the
relief we I mean we all share these
melodies and things so it's fun
you
you